first of all congratulations you all are
so amazing in this movie and it was such
a joy to watch all of you
um Kate I want to start with you because
you sort of start the movie off because
your voice is the voiceover and the
narration that sort of threads
throughout the movie I know this wasn't
originally the case it was going to be
Ben wish all I was wondering how it sort
of felt being asked to do that and
having that sort of responsibility of
being the fat the thing that threads the
movie
um I mean I think it's honestly one of
the best I want to say compliment but
that's not one of that's I don't think
that's the word I want to use but um
it's like the Dishonored yeah it's the
biggest honor in the world to be asked
to do that especially by the incredible
Sarah Paulie and out of everyone in this
cast I was kind of just flabbergasted
that she asked me
um and it just felt so incredibly
special and
um I just I wanted to do her her work
she put so much work into writing
um ocha's voice over lines because they
were um different than what Ben was
originally gonna
um say and she put so so much effort and
love into those lines and I really just
wanted to put as much work as I could
and to give into doing them justice so
well you definitely did and it was very
very incredible
um speaking of Sarah Paulie Liv I know
that you sort of connected with her
after directing a short film which is so
amazing I kind of want to know what you
learned as a filmmaker from being
directed by someone like her uh I
learned so much
um it was a like phenomenal experience
like the more that I will get from any
uh like University or Film School
um like just being completely immersed
in the work and her
um her technique and like I would just
just watch her
24 7 just at any any point um there's
like watch her talk to people watch how
she
um like conducts the room how she works
the room how she makes things happen I
would often um hang out after cut and
just like watch them set up the next
shot and I would go and talk to the DP
and go to talk to Sarah and be like what
are we doing next like how do you
um how are we gonna do this like if this
person is talking to this person across
the room and it's like a like a circle
formation like how are we gonna do this
um uh like point of access or like um
action Access wise
um it was just like I feel like I took
so much away from it and I put a lot of
um a lot of that learning into my own
work now because I'm still making films
I'm still a film student yeah um
Michelle I feel like your character sort
of serves as a bridge in a way between
the adults and the kids and it's sort of
in that in between space between like
adulthood and Adolescence still is that
kind of how you saw it and approached it
as well yeah it's funny at first it kind
of It kind of developed into that way
um and you're right it was a great Gap
in between because I do feel like she
was still
um
in her in her more juvenile state but
also she's on the cusp of becoming the
matriarch of her own family and and
using the experience but she's watching
her mom and she's watching her sister
and she's seeing her nieces and she's
seeing everything and she's trying to
make a decision of how she's going to
tackle that and who she's going to step
in like what shoe she's going to step
into but it's also very daunting because
there's such change happening now so she
stuck in between the older world where
she's just now getting quote unquote the
freedom to be a woman but then that
freedom is now developing into something
that's even bigger than herself and it's
breaking all of what she had known
before and she now has to just like
everyone else Define who she's going to
be afterwards so it it's a it's a bridge
between Generations but it's also a
journey for her to find herself amongst
these women because we're all gonna go
set up
um somewhere else and then find our
place within that and I think think
she's gonna go to her new beginning a
lot stronger yeah 100 and something else
I really loved about your character was
that we sort of got to touch on Mental
Health in a way and how
um like trauma can really sort of
manifest itself into like physical
responses was that something that felt
very important for you to sort of
portray as well yes
um a hundred percent I think that mental
health needs to be talked about so much
more and and people need to understand
that it is something that happens to
people it's all part of there being an
emotional being and the more we talk
about it the more understanding we have
and the more validated you can feel
experiencing these things because I
think anxiety is
um you know
um a secret agent it pops in so many in
so many different ways in so many
different forms from so many different
triggers and the more we can understand
how to care for ourselves and our
anxiety
um in order to process trauma uh the
more we can start having those
conversations that make it more
to make it realized that it is common
and you're not alone very very well said
I really really love that something else
I love about this movie is that all the
characters do have such depth and really
get their moments to shine I'm curious
if you could play any other character in
this movie who would you want to sort of
sink your teeth into besides your own
character I want Salome so I was gonna
say yeah
as an actor I had to contain myself
internally as Michelle I was like get it
like so
um yeah I feel that I feel that that's
amazing
um I really also love I'm just not angry
people
yeah we really have the range of
emotions on this one yeah so great
um and one of the emotions that is kind
of unexpected I feel like is the fact
that there is a lot of Comedy throughout
and there is are these moments of really
effective humor um and a lot of them I
think come from you all's characters can
you talk a little bit about playing you
know maybe some of the lighter moments
juxtaposed next to these very you know
dark serious issues I mean I think I
think
um having lighter moments is really
important in films like this because it
helps to highlight and make the darker
moments way more emotional and just way
more
um impactful and I think especially with
this film The Mennonite woman that Sarah
met with made it really clear that it um
it was important to have humor and
laughter in the room because
um they were saying that when when
Mennonite women gather together without
the men there is a lot of laughter and
there's a lot of touching and physical
contact and
um Sarah really really tried to to
highlight that I think and she did a
wonderful job of it so well thank you
all so much it was such a pleasure
getting to speak to you and I can't wait
for everyone to see the movie thank you
thank you